after Russia's President Vladimir Putin
announced partial mobilization in
September hundreds of thousands left
Russia German politicians promised back
then protection to those who refused to
fight in Ukraine it turns out that
actually getting asylum in Germany is
not that easy for Russian draft Invaders
our correspondents met with a few men
were trying
Denis Supreme decided to flee Russia
immediately after President Vladimir
Putin announced a partial mobilization
I don't want to fight because no one is
attacking Russia
I had a military service card I served
in the Russian army in 2011 and 2012.
and this military card is proof that I
would be drafted again this time
no I know
Dennis crossed the border into Georgia
on a bicycle and then flew to Germany he
requested asylum in the Berlin airport
he has been to three different migrant
centers since then most recently here in
windsdorf south of Berlin
we are not allowed to film on the
premises but ironically it is right
outside the former Soviet forces German
headquarters now abandoned there are
more than a dozen men like Dennis here
asked why they came to Germany they all
have the same answer
the media reported that Chancellor
Schultz said Germany would Grant Asylum
to Russians who support European values
and don't want to be drafted
a German interior Ministry spokesperson
confirmed to DW that Russians who
refused military service can apply for
Asylum here each case however will be
considered individually but most of
these men enter Germany either through
other U countries or with visas issued
by those countries according to what's
known as the Dublin regulations Asylum
Seekers must make their claim in the
first EU country they set food in or
that issues them a Visa not wherever
they end up
Dennis has already been refused Asylum
exactly on those grounds now he is being
sent to Sweden but not all European
countries are willing to Grant Asylum to
draft evaders from Russia and these men
are afraid that they will eventually be
sent back to Russia where either the
army or prison awaits them
Natalia smallencheva filed this report
she's with DW's Russia desk and joins us
in the studio now Natalia tell us more
about these men what do they think about
the war in Ukraine
so these men have actually left Russia
because they didn't want to become part
of this war but it's unclear how
politically aware they are what's
happening in Russia has been happening
for the past years out of all the men
we've spoken and it's you know around
five seven people who are in this uh you
know in this refugee camp here in
Germany
um only one was active politically
active before he was going to the
protest and actually taking part in
local elections and he was planning to
leave Russia already after the beginning
of full-scale and invasion in February
other men have been seemed to live their
normal life after the beginning of the
war and only when the politics came
directly to their houses and were taking
them to the war then they decided they
want to flee so what is the impact of
all those young men leaving Russia
I think it's remain to be seen in the
next years but estimated hundreds of
thousands people have left Russia and
these are young skilled men this is the
core of economy and especially people
who are working in I.T sector in
Academia Engineers those people are to
bring country forward and we're gonna
see a big brain drain and this can
affect Russian economy together with the
Western sanctions we can see that Russia
will be sliding into their recession I
think in next years now there are talks
that there's a new wave of mobilization
on the horizon what can you tell us
about that yeah a lot of people are
fearing this and these men have been
spoken to this is also the reason they
don't want to come back because they are
afraid they'll be drafted again because
the initial numbers of draftees we
haven't seen the numbers but there were
rumors that there's 300 000 people there
are not enough clearly for Russia to
continue this war and we see that Russia
is planning to go on
um continue with the war in Ukraine for
some time still and it will need new
soldiers and but it's very tricky to
announce a new wave of mobilization
because we see that the first one was
very unpopular political move and if
before the majority of Russians kind of
ignored the war or they preferred to
close shut their eyes to it now it's
become impossible because it is coming
to every house and every family and
taking the man to the war that's why
it's meant to be seen whether the
authorities in Russia will make this
step to go and actually announce the
second wave of normalization or they'll
prefer to do it as hidden undercover and
not you know not angry and anger the
people more
gw's Russia desk thank you very much